he has been traveling the world to
promote this film and we finally have
him back in the Rich Eisen show orbit
the secret life of pets - and his
beloved Kansas City Chiefs and so much
more on the mind of you Eric Stonestreet
good to see you good to see you can't
I'm glad I'm here you know I love coming
here I love having you like home here
but you have literally been everywhere
it's like well you're in Europe viewer
was in I was in Europe in New York City
those just two those two places okay and
then here to very large places yeah I
went from LA to London London to LA and
then was here for one night and then
flew to Kansas City and then back and
then to New York like all in four days
my gosh it was great fantastic my body
doesn't that still know what time at
least you have the proper footwear for
that sir yes sir Air Force one now are
you in Lamar Odom wearing the same shoes
today I don't know if his was the gray
stripe these are the gray stripe because
I wanted a little contrast on them but
yeah those are them Brock we don't
wonder notices those are tight those are
clean very clean calm thanks very clean
clean you know what you want to know why
I'm wearing Air Force One please go for
it is because at the draft of course I
watch every square house of coverage
that I can watch of the drafted in
Kansas City Andy Reid was doing an
interview and I took a screenshot of his
picture of his shoes and I sent it to my
friend Mitch Schwartz who's of tackle
I'm wearing what are these shoes he's
wearing he goes Oh Andy though he wears
Air Force Ones so I took that picture
and Andy Reid is the reason why I'm back
into Air Force Ones I'm like they got to
be comfortable freeze where he's wearing
sensible shoes he's on his feet a lot
and Andy Reid's wearing Air Force Ones
I'm getting myself a pair Air Force Ones
fly he was wearing tan ones I'm like
they are so sick then I my first Air
Force Ones was a green purchase for st.
Patrick's Day Parade in Kansas City yeah
and then I got these and then I got a
pair of blue ones coming and then when
when chief season starts I'm gonna get
red ones but Air Force Ones are my new
thing and now the home of the 2023
National Football League Draft yeah wait
Kansas City I knew it was happening I
knew like I couldn't tell anyone because
RG told you your buddy your buddy the
goods tell he didn't tell me but I knew
from the Kansas City Sports Commission
that it was
happening what's it gonna look like you
think it's gonna be awesome you know
there's they know where it is physically
I have an idea what was in their page of
a few areas but I think what's gonna
make it great is and I think what
Nashville did so well was made it like
about what Nashville is about so I would
love to see Kansas City you know we have
the amazing American royal barbecue
competition every year I would love for
us to see see us move that you know to
around that time for that one year and
get all these people coming in to
competing in these barbecue contests
around the NFL Draft I mean be amazing
well I mean the barbecue food that we
had in Nashville was an integral part of
the draft yeah I mean there's no bag in
the middle of the third day you're like
well sitting there it's like our 6:00
on that Saturday yeah we're perched up
in putting it next to Tootsie's on
Broadway and there was an establishment
about three doors down and it would just
laugh so good you know and I've been
with wood is smell awesome tape why
would you ever do a show cooking with
wood with Erics with Eric Stonestreet
have you considered doing something like
that yeah a round food I'm passionate
food guy well you're passionate about
you have made me some incredible
barbecue eat my brisket you've I've
eaten your brisket this is not a
metaphor for anything yeah and you guys
pipe down yeah I've had this man's
brisket they're just laughing cuz they
weren't invited they were not invited
but you came in like you it was but by
the way I mean talk about how seriously
this man takes it you showed up in the
kitchen like you came around the corner
and you had these buck blue black gloves
like these black gloves on I'm like I'm
about to get whacked about the latter it
was I forget remember I think we won
yeah no yeah it was the multi it was it
was the most left-handed throw dream
that's right against that Broncos
than I get that's what it was and now
he's coming to your big slick yeah we're
very we're sad you're not gonna be there
you and this show have been so
supportive of thanks Eric in Kansas City
and we appreciate that so much and just
literally on my way here Tara our
president said to tell you we're sad
you're not gonna be here well I mean
it's just for various reasons just this
time at this time of year just wasn't in
the cards you know I would make it air
fine and I absolutely could
but people people can check it out big
slick KC org so you know what we're
talking about and you can donate to
Children's Mercy Hospital Paul Rudd
Jason Sudeikis Rob Riggle myself Dave
Koechner we're all from the area do the
charity check it out you'll and it's so
absurdly popular you're holding it in an
actual arena this year we moved it to
the Sprint Center which is like the
Staples Center here in la magia actually
owns the Sprint Center Sprint Center in
AEG have been so kind to us and in
giving us the Sprint Center for a
reduced cost a charitable cost so we can
have it there and we're hoping that this
year we raised over 2 million dollars
would put us at 10 million for 10 years
for the children there through the
hospital some easing yeah it really is
is worthy of a round of applause it
really is that's awesome yeah and my
homes are gonna be there well Holmes is
coming Patrick is coming I'm very
excited about that
Kansas City loves him and he's a he's a
good he's a good guy and it's very nice
of him to come because as I've said to
him and to everyone you know and people
inviting him is like I know he gets
asked to do everything so for sure
gotta pick and choose in the fact that
he's you reach out to him did you reach
out well I just yeah well yeah I mean
but the group effort yeah that's a group
effort
I mean we all just make him shirt make
sure he knows that we get it when we
know that he knows that he'll be taken
care of Eric Stonestreet here on the
Rich Eisen show what do you make of this
whole conversation of the overtime rules
potentially being changed based off of
the AFC Championship game loss Eric well
about that it's fine that it's based off
that but I've been thinking for a long
time before I was a victim of it
my team was a victim of it that it
needed to be changed I mean I just feel
like the notion of the name
nature of a game that ends in a tie
wouldn't it make the most sense that
each team gets a chance mm-hmm to touch
the foot to touch the floor the issue
with that is is that if the Chiefs had
gotten the ball back in that game well
they would have had the benefit of going
for it on every fourth down which the
team who touches the ball first would
not have had the benefit of them then
change it from the then each team gets
the ball up to 35 you don't have a
problem with that certainly when you've
got potential free you know returners
that you were moving from the game and
it's a big benefit for one team that you
know I just know that it's like to say
that we're not gonna do anything seems
like we're a creative group of people
who love a sport that feels like there's
a there's a tiny little hole here that
could be improved it's like well let's
be creative like let's figure figure it
out I'm not saying it might be that
we'll be perfect and maybe the first
version of it won't be perfect it will
be like well that doesn't seem really
fair but let's I mean I think the notion
of a defensive and offensive struggle
means that each team gets a chance to
score a touchdown and so yeah III got I
just I just would never want it to take
it away at the college game to me
removes such an important part of the
game with special teams you know you
know and so that that's the issue for me
is that you'd be changing if you go the
version I just said you know well then
don't do that like just give each give
each team of possession the possession
about the idea that you should just stop
them defensively well but the game has
been the the nature of why we're here
yes
either proves that you've been very good
at it meaning if it's seven seven yes or
not very good at it which is 35 35 or 40
40 whatever it is right so it's not what
was the score of the Chiefs Patriots I
blocked it out I can't remember what
hurt man but I mean well I mean the
regular season one was like forty three
forty years so what I'm saying is
because we the defense of the Chiefs
wasn't able to stop the Patriots for the
whole game then it really comes down to
if you're gonna go that way and say well
you know stop them we haven't stopped
them so now it's just a coin flip now
you're you're putting the game into the
hands of just a coin flip
so that's what I'm saying it's like well
our defense wasn't able to stop the
Patriots the Patriots defense wasn't
really able to stop us so let's let's go
mano-a-mano again I mean it's the same
deal yeah 3731 what's the final score
let's you know I don't need it like
because the thing of it is is like I
don't root against the Patriots like I
root for the Chiefs when the Patriots
are playing another team I don't give a
crap if they win or not I only care when
they're playing against my team and I
also am a true sportsman in that we have
to beat them like that's the truth right
like and if we can't then they keep
deserving to win all this stuff it's
just the bottom line
but it's this you know it's these paints
only being talked about because the
Patriots were and that's not true twice
it happen and the Super Bowl wouldn't
happen in the Aether's championship game
that's not that's benefited both times
by winning excuse me and that's why it's
not for discussion you say what it is it
doesn't benefit Chris and then it's like
well now we should look at this rule let
me let me disabuse you of that notion
sir the overtime in which meet you is
that too big of a word over there no I'm
just saying I'm about to I'm about to
I'm about to and if this mic could be
dropped I would drop it because it's
only happened twice the overtimes rule
were initially changed to go from sudden
death no matter what with a place kick
to what we have now because of a game
that took place between the Saints and
the Vikings Patriots had no bacon in
that game the whole concept of like
let's make sure at least one team that
touches the ball if it is only a field
goal that's put on the board first came
out of the fact that the Saints and the
Vikings went to overtime and that's how
it ended where the Saints just kicked a
field goal and that was all she wrote
and that's to these back to that
I don't like that I like the fact look I
like the fact that Brady marched them
down and just that's it absolutely in
both games and they were fortunate
enough obviously they get the coin real
quick role reversal sure do role
reversal it's it's whoever your team is
you think it's unfair but this isn't a
new debate because of that game and
because of the Patriots like people
there are people that think the overtime
rules should be changed for a long time
and this is just a new interesting
conversation
maybe the mahomes effect because like
they wanted to see what mahomes could do
right I why why would we should we be
opposed to that let the Patriots defense
stop us and if they do then it's like
well now that happened yeah yeah we have
a game let's be fair and balance to ask
him a poll question although you already
said that you you wouldn't choose the
Patriots right here what is it go ahead
yes the Povich team do you most like to
root against Alabama football Patriots
Warriors Duke basketball Yankees none of
that none of those really I root I used
to root solely against kku
in basketball you know I the kansas as
you root against you know you root for
k-state anyone playing right but as I've
gotten older I've stopped rooting
against I'm not a big against Rueter I
hate when people applaud other teams
misfortunes like it's like that's not
the spirit of sport you know right cheer
for your team and then there are also
professional athletes out there and you
couldn't do anything they're doing right
like that's how I think of it so but in
that list you know I don't really follow
a professional basketball so so none of
them okay me I root against the Patriots
in my own brain when we're playing each
other but not ever I mean I think I want
I think Tom Brady's amazing I think Bill
Belichick is amazing you have evolved as
a human beings what you're saying well I
just felt that way but it's those people
that bring whoa those guys
and the folks like it that bring a
distaste some [ __ ] yes it's your
word I'm sorry to bring you down to my
level but I just can't wait like
honestly I'm very excited not for the
Patriots to Demont be demise or anything
like that but I am so very curious to
see if the Patriots and error ends a
little bit and they go through a little
bit of a rebuilding phase I cannot wait
to see if you still talk the way you
talk or you're just going to live in the
past that's what's gonna be interesting
do you have enough response to that
Chris that's a good question by the way
well wait in 10 years when Tom Brady
retired I hope and here's again I hope
Tom Brady plays for the next 10 years I
don't what I like the NFL with Tom Brady
in it not me too I mean all good things
come to an end the end is coming it's of
course so we'll just see what happens
and you have to look at me and like the
the good good parts just starting for my
team what's amazing for you guys I don't
think about that's what I said to you
and Rudd and and every Chiefs fan I'm
like tell tell me what it's like tell me
how that tell me how that feels we don't
know well but what you got to feel it
last year and you already know it at
least as Jets fans you're hoping Santa
models that guy you don't I mean like
you're hoping we'll always have the gist
you know that you just said you know
that you're at the beginning is that the
pot of gold might be there you don't
know when it's gonna happen you think
it's gonna be there you hope it's gonna
be there yeah but you know there's a
rainbow that's forming yeah we're going
on that ride I mean yeah Jets fans are
hope and Arnold's that guy you even know
yeah yeah yeah that's true well maybe he
hasn't shown up it's a new time for me
in Kansas City with the Chiefs you've
known me a long time and I'm down
through 2012 season for example two and
fourteen or whatever we were doing
twelve rough hard very awful but with
Brett being as aggressive as he is like
anyone
vgm Joe and Andy and you know the
president mark and Clark just let's go
let's go let's go do it
well I'll tell you you know you were
there when you were you were hanging out
at the NFL Network that against in the
week they played the Ravens yeah the
week where you thought it was all over
it's fourth and ten oh and my home's
just ran around and flung it in here and
and converted and I took a picture of
you in that moment yeah and you you did
not move from your from the from your
look of resignation that you had
pre-snap
it's amazing like look it's it's it's
very exciting for me and I just you know
I just want I just want I lived up to
his potential and the Chiefs to live up
to their potential and just go for it
and you know I know let's talk about
secret life of pets to again it's in
theaters near you know it's up to you oh
good I love having you here before we
talk about the movie a little bit I want
to talk about the photographs that I saw
on your Instagram feed at Eric
Stonestreet it's it's great you got to
follow him on Twitter as well that's you
with Harrison Ford
yep matching hair oh yeah who is in this
film was this the first time you'd met
him yeah first time I'd ever met him
first time I think I've ever been even
near him can't think of another reason I
would have ever been in a room or an
area with Harrison Ford but that's like
I'm sorry but that is meeting a movie
star like we don't have that necessarily
like that's like meeting Gregory Peck
that's 50 years ago right that's my
girlfriend meeting him yeah and that's
Chris Melandri the illumination guy
that's in the striped shirt yes what are
you talking about well I just Chris I
asked Chris millet andriy to introduce
me and you know and Harrison said I've
seen your show and you guys are really
great in this movie and then we talked
for a little bit and I just said that I
can officially check this this moment
off my list and I appreciate appreciate
it what was it now what would you have
wanted him to say more that he watched
Modern Family and appreciated what you
were doing
and that you're great in this movie or
just started talking about the Chiefs
with you like he's it's not hard a fan
as anything else like what would that
hello I want Harrison Ford's admiration
I mean any actor would love to have a
compliment from Harrison Ford so I would
say there I mean he's never gonna make
me more of a Chiefs fan
no I know that but just the fact that
you could just chop it up like that with
him ya know he's on a different plane
he's not talking about Kelsey you know I
have had moments like that where I've
met people that I really admire and look
up to and then we could talk about
something that I'm really passionate
about whether that be food or you got an
example that's happened to you or well
I'll think about it we have more
segments right and so for Dana Carvey
Xin this never met him before what a
great guy so nice it was his birthday
yesterday and they got him a cake and it
just was a big pile of look like dog
poop no cake it's hilarious exactly the
cake you and I so you've been running
around with Kevin Hart - oh my god yeah
you got video of that I have I have
hounded him and hounded him and hounded
Emmy on my instagram people can see that
I know it's funny Minh a really funny
position do you talk football with him I
know he's a die already he's a fellow
he's a Phillies guy or a yes guy we
don't really talk to football that much
okay cuz you might have another love of
Andy Reed in common I think Phillies or
the Philadelphia people are happy with
our other the other Chiefs coach they
have right yeah I'm sure what are those
people doing over there are they having
a party I have no idea there dear ding
okay so what what are what a family I
should expect the usual right from this
movie it looks it's hilarious you know
it's different than the it's different
than the first one a little bit in that
I feel like this one has a little even
more heart than the first one
like I get oh I've seen it twice now and
the last moment of the movie I'm not
gonna give it anything away makes me
miss t no Kari makes made made me miss
yesterday oh my gosh yeah yeah wait to
see it and I can't wait to see this it's
a roller coaster man it starts and when
you get to that moment it's just
action
the editing and the sound mixing and all
that people don't realize like we go in
we lay our voices down and then these
amazing talented animators and editors
and colorist and all these people put
all this stuff together as though we're
in the same room with each other right
and I'm recording it weeks and weeks
apart from patent or whoever I'm talking
to and then you you meet these people
and you're like thank you for making it
so great you're literally doing it
yourself though huh yeah you talk to
yourself now do they already have some
other people's tracks laid down in your
response times okay I don't ever want to
hear that I mean if they offered I would
listen to it maybe a little bit right
very specific but I just try to do like
different versions of the same line so
that then when they get there they have
options no it's awesome like I said I
can't I can't wait and modern family is
next year next year yeah we're gonna
dun-dun-dun do you know how it's gonna
end
no yeah I did but I don't know I don't
think they know yet I think they're they
start work today actually the writers
are back in for the first day today and
now they'll start carving out what the
final season looks like I think it would
be great if like Peter Dinklage comes
out towards the end and starts deciding
who survived remember on your social
media were you upset about the ending
yeah okay I think that's ridiculous
why because it's fake I don't see a
dragon breathing fire entities so Eric
people are invested in the characters
storylines that have been built up over
eight nine ten or so years yeah so if it
matters then it means a lot to them I
know but it's it's it's it's not like oh
no no I don't feel like personally
offended yeah you know that's appointed
yeah that I but I don't think there's
any way you would have been not
disappointed as that big of a thigh saw
the documentary it's great have you seen
that yeah the game of Thrones episode
one outright and they be had a moment
where they had the cast Eric Stonestreet
here in the rich okay where they had me
they had well I got a reset for the
radio on that's a living professional
dude you're amazing thanks Eric
Stonestreet around the Rich Eisen show
they had a moment where the the cast was
doing a table read of the final episode
and I don't know if this was for editing
purposes or not spoiler alert they read
the the moment where Jon Snow takes care
of Daenerys and then say end of Game of
Thrones did you hear that and then it
clapped does that mean that they edited
out the whole last part of the table
read or was that legitimately once upon
a time the original ending cuz if that
was the end like fade to black now we're
kind of talking I would feel like some
other loose ends hadn't been tied up but
at least that would have been just like
a wholly you know what moment yeah and
then we're done but people like The
Sopranos
you know like complain about that I
still didn't I didn't mind that ending I
thought it was cool everybody complains
about everything that's where we are as
a world that's by the way that's that's
true like over to like over time I'm
guilty of it but you're guilty of it too
four seasons misidentifying why the
overtime rules are under under
discussion that is not the case because
it's the pager why the NFL would care
for example like how much air is in the
ball he's mister green wedge from
Trivial Pursuit over there game that
they govern let's take a break we have a
couple of start bench cuts for you
because I know that you'd like to do
that I love start okay very good
when we come back as promised segments
we shall have it with Eric Stonestreet
check out again The Secret Life of pets
2 in theaters new you starting this
Friday back with Eric to finish up the
show and let you know what's going on
the rest of the week here on the show
the Bleacher Report app connects you to
the moments that matter
faster follow your friends and give your
take on highlights scores and more
download the BR app today Eric
Stonestreet wrapping up this show right
here on the Rich Eisen show final poll
results brought to you by Capital One
which is reimagined banking by offering
savings and checking accounts with no
fees or minimums and one of the nation's
best savings rates approval is required
Capital One NA member FDIC Capital One
what's in your wallet what's in your
wallets Chris what do you have over
there the team you like the route
against the most goals a warrior's 7% oh
boy the Duke basketball 14% by the way
Duke is the character that Eric
Stonestreet plays I think which is why
my daughter when she filled out a an
NCAA bracket for the first time in her
life two years ago chose Duke to win it
all because she loves your character so
me loving you as I do Eric and calling
you a close friend it was wonderful
but me despising Duke as I do it was a
bittersweet moment for me to hear those
words come out of my daughter's mouth
I'm not gonna lie yes because I would
have thought that's who I would have
voted for in this poll tell you that we
know who won Yankees have 15% Alabama
20% and the six times Super Bowl
champion New England Patriots 40 44
that's what I said earlier is enjoy the
fact that your team is as generous
because at some point you're gonna
you're probably gonna go back to your
relevancy like most of a lot of the
other teams down if I doubt it okay
see like you were before a Michigan man
canonists trends trends happen do not
forget the Michigan man came out of the
Mist 199th overall that one year the
bills and cowboys era I've changed all
right you have the dropper yes go for it
please it's gonna be quiet or cut up all
right start bench cut start one bench
one cut one Eric Stonestreet the Kansas
City chief you'd most want your sister
to date Patrick
Travis Kelce Andy Reid we're gonna mari
is dying right now
she loves Travis Kelce so much but I
want her in the warm comfort grasp of an
auntie okay there you go well I think
people have to check maybe she's
throwing it was like you had your chance
yeah she does love Kelsey huh he'll be a
big slick he comes every year to America
loves Travis in the NFL that needs to
change the most start bench cut over
time possession fumbling through the end
zone man
I hate that reviewable pass interference
start bench cut so you starting the one
that needs to change the most and you're
benching and then oh yeah I forgot that
I'm gonna start over time possession I'm
gonna bench review it pass interference
and I'm gonna cut end zone fumbling
that's you fumble the ball out at the
half inch yard line it's your ball it
goes two more inches into the end zone
it's the defense I have to be honest
than I asked it I'm don't get don't go
deep on this because I can't remember
but I asked the goods personally about
this and he gave me a really good reason
and a really good understanding of the
opposite of it which he always does with
every issue I ever bring to him yes and
I can't remember what he said okay
that's good enough for me so I've got my
work cut out for ya you got my let me
tell you something I sent Roger a text
and said hey can you send can the NFL
send something for the swag bags at big
slick he sent 72 footballs for art and
then he and then the other 25 are going
to the kids that come to the magic show
on Thursday night at Children's Mercy
Hospital that's awesome Roger needs more
good publicity that's all I'm saying by
the way the nickname of the football
Duke Duke see it's awful circle
unbelievable it's all around Duke
alright last one last one I know the
answer to this but
so obviously secret life of pets - and
theaters near you on Friday
what's the best pet to own dog catfish
Oh God
they'll to fo did you come up with this
one bench pat cut fish like literally
cut fish then fry it neither how's your
dog Roscoe is amazing my name is
Roscoe's his Instagram rescued ya you
rescue he's a great dog
Roscoe you know he's mostly American
Staffordshire Terrier 25 percent Cattle
Dog 12 percent Chinese shar-pei and 12
percent unidentifiable money the DNA did
the DNA test stuck my finger right no no
I did watch more scientific approach
than that but my vet said those are
really reliable and my other dog Coleman
I always had him for 15 years and always
thought you know was told he was half
beagle half Jack Russell terrier Kennedy
and they test they didn't know that came
back 50/50 Jack Russell beagle because I
think they're accurate shoutout to my
girlfriend right now she's getting her
10-year token of working at Children's
Mercy Hospital in Los Angeles right now
as I'm doing this beautiful yeah ten
years she's been a nurse there at
Children's Mercy which is where we met
doing the charity event somebody who was
it that said oh so that's a kickback to
the charity right Eric you're the best
man no Eric Stonestreet on Twitter and
Instagram secret life of pets and to go
see it you're gonna love in theaters on
Friday for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app